pour évoquer ton adolescence ton enfance
je vais te faire une petite interview
première fois bon tu es prêt
premièrement première boum un message je
me rappelle de toutes les bombes
d'ailleurs toujours pareil on m'a invité
pour faire rire la première partie de la
soirée et arriver on me demande de
rester près du buffet
j'étais le dernier moi c'est une fille
première idole première
idole comment ça va je dis que j'aime
vraiment beaucoup Claude François tu
connais toutes ces chansons par coeur
pas mal pas mal pas mal je suis pas
fétichiste quoi pour moi je dis ça j'ai
acheté un costume de lui aux enchères
est-ce que tu sais qui a écrit les
lundis au soleil c'est qui un copain qui
s'appelle Patrick Juvet
c'est dans un autocar dans le fond
avec pas la plus belle
en direction de l'Italie j'ai dû être le
dernier dans ma classe d'habitude le
chauffeur il est à l'avant
je pensais qu'on pouvait pas respirer
finement
la dernière c'était avant-hier alors la
première
au lycée
premier vrai amour ça doit être
un Muriel Robin j'avoue que je suis
vraiment tombée bien amoureux d'elle
première expérience sexuelle ah bah oui
on m'avait dit moi il fait absolument
merde j'avais 19 ans enfin absolument
que je fasse un acte à l'acte et je me
suis renseigné sur la fille la plus
facile du lycée et toutes les accepter
ça a marché
c'est passé comme une lettre à la poste
1er juin
1er juin c'était
très longtemps au lycée
n'importe quoi en fumait du café du thé
pour que ça fasse
premier procès
je vous le rappelle rappelons-le Pierre
Palmade et pas l'immigator de Sylvie
jolie donc ça m'avait énervé quoi
qu'il le disent qui le dévoile
premier bide premier bide ce soir je
trouve vraiment sympa
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu